it's a very good question certainly it's
a very important industry we know that
it's a very complex industry its
manifold and really the solution to the
energy problem has to come from many
sources not just one and so the first
thing to do is really to understand the
complexity and the richness of the
energy picture and then to figure out
where the person who is interested in
the industry can make a contribution and
there are many places to make
contributions both from the standpoint
of conceptually as well as many
scientific and technical innovations so
for the energy industry there's huge
there's no question there's a huge unmet
need and so you know in some cases you
wonder okay if I'm if I'm going to do
something or working on something is it
really going to matter and there's no
question that this is an area this is
one of those big problems and the
National Academy of Engineering spent a
lot of time identifying big problems
that engineers could help solve and
energy from many dimensions you know it
was significant on that list and so
since there's such a big unmet medical
need there's going to be a lot of
solutions so there's lots of
opportunities to to get involved and
make things happen in the energy area
inevitably we are looking for cleaner
energy a more let's say responsible
carbon footprint we're looking for less
dependence on fossil we are looking for
find it tapping into the the energies
sources that are all around us so there
is going to be innovation in all aspects
I think there'll be innovation in
nuclear I think nuclear is going to be
prediction going to be an important part
we have to learn how to handle some of
the issues but it's going to be you know
we have to learn about renewable energy
we have to learn about capturing carbon
big issue we have to learn about power
storage so it's it's that's why it's
such an exciting area especially for
engineering and science based companies
because there's a lot of opportunity I
think it's going to be a fine tuning of
all of the pieces that are currently
available but with an eye to create
cleaner and more sustainable energy so
it's it's definitely going to be a mix
it will be an evolution from where we
are because things do move slowly so one
of my favorite examples is I just bought
an electric car and the EV one which was
an electric car developed and sold by
general motors in the late 1990s their
their concept car was originally in 1990
they put it on the market in 1996 they
quit selling it in 99 and then they
crushed them all and you know now we
Dowe forward another decade and and
electric cars aren't ubiquitous yet but
they are becoming more prevalent I have
mine charging over by trusted her and I
just got a text on my iPhone telling me
the charging was finished and I can turn
the charging off remotely which is which
is pretty neat nice convergence of
technologies but it's just for me isn't
just a specific example of how things
take a long time to evolve
of especially the energy in especially
in the energy area
in a way look at the Sun the Sun is a
nuclear reactor it's happening
continuously there's fusion that's
that's all there that that sorcerer so
in a way our source of energy is fusion
ideally if we could harness fusion maybe
not twenty years but maybe a hundred or
two hundred years okay again Star Trek
I've forgotten some of my old structure
movies um but you know the answer may be
in that because I think solar energy we
can't quite do fusion yet today but it's
happening up there so how do we tap it
better okay how do we store it and in a
sense renewable energy is another form
of solar energy okay if you use biomass
it is the Sun whose you know it's it's
it's it's it's one full circle life is
one full circle there so I think as we
move into the next couple of decades
solar energy is going to be key and if I
had only one source I would try to tap
as much as possible into either directly
the Sun or indirectly through biomass or
renewable as Ricardo mentioned i'm i'm a
big proponent of the Sun and it's there
every day I do have solar panels on my
house so that doesn't completely charged
my car but it's helps a little bit
towards the electricity that's needed
needed from our car I'm also a bit but
when people say so or they typically
think of you know sort annals or
photovoltaics you know Ricardo dimension
fission fusion fusion I've got to get
that right fusion and I'm also intrigued
by some of the things for example people
are doing with algae to make oils for
feet socks for the chemical industry so
a very direct way of taking the solar
energy using the lg's photosynthesis in
thetic processes to produce oils which
you can then take and
and uses petrochemical feedstocks
I actually think specially for the
developed world it would be fantastic
because it'll be nice and quiet and
we'll all for a moment come in true
touch with nature okay that's the easy
answer I mean that's complicated they
are hey you know suddenly you'll talk to
each other I mean look what happened
when when power went out in the East
Coast my wife was actually there in New
York New Yorkers started talking to each
other for God's sake so I I think I
think the world will survive so if there
was one day without energy we would have
so many unmet needs identified that we
could keep everyone busy as
entrepreneurs for a really long time
you